[D. Evans] The answer is the first 2 can be produced.
The third one cannot.
And the way to see that is to follow the rules.
So if we start from sentence we only have 1 rule from sentence,
so we're always going to end up with subject, verb, object.
We also only have 1 rule from subject and 1 rule from object,
so we're always going to end up with noun, verb, followed by object,
which also is replaced with noun.
From here we have lots of choices.
We can replace the noun with Python,
we can replace the verb with eat,
and we can replace the second noun with cookies.
That will derive the first sentence.
We could replace the second noun with Python,
using instead the second choice.
That would derive the second sentence.
There's no way to produce the third one.
We can get close. We can turn the noun into I following this rule.
We can turn the verb into like following this rule.
We can't turn the noun into eat. The noun can be either I, python, or cookies.
That's why we can't derive the third sentence.
The important thing about replacement grammars
is we can describe a large language--in fact, an infinitely large language--
with a small set of rules.
This language itself is quite small, but we'll see how to describe much bigger languages
still using a small number of rules soon.
And it's very precise.
We can figure out exactly what sentences are in the language
just by following the rules here doing replacements.